qui les a jetés comme ça dans la flûte
c'est la police politique c'est chaouch
et sous scellés communistes qui ont fait
ça abbas a aussi secoué 1989 en roumanie
les télés du monde entier diffusent des
images d'un charnier dans la ville de
timisoara
des corps mutilés des milliers de morts
annoncés mais rien de tout ça n'est vrai
il s'agit de l'une des plus grandes
affaires de désinformation mondiale du
20e siècle la confusion la plus totale
d'une manipulation nous avons distordue
la vérité quelques éléments de contexte
en 1989 la roumanie est gouvernée par le
dictateur communiste nicolae ceausescu
droits de l'homme bafoués pénurie de
nourriture répression violente
le monde entier s'inquiète la situation
en or en roumanie est dramatique
la roumanie est l'un des derniers pays
du bloc soviétique en décembre 89
le peuple se révolte à commencer par la
ville de timisoara
à l'ouest la répression des violences je
les ai vus écraser des enfants sur leur
char je les ai vus entrer dans des
immeubles et tué tous les habitants 22
décembre 1989
les journaux les radios les jt annonce
le chiffre de 4000 630 morts et très
vite des images choc circulent des
habitants ont découvert la nuit dernière
un charnier ceausescu est un monstre
en voici la preuve basescu ces images
émeuvent l'opinion mondiale en roumanie
elle attise la révolte et précipite la
chute de ceausescu le 25 décembre 1989
il est jugé et exécuté un mois plus tard
le 25 janvier 1990 rebondissements la
roumanie maintenant avec une polémique
sur la réalité des évènements de
timisoara
il s'agissait en fait d'une opération
montée de toutes pièces pour après se
impressionné le monde entier
pourtant dès le départ des sources
locales affirmé que tout était faux le
docteur hélène moussa médecin légiste à
l'hôpital sous des chiennes de timisoara
avait dénoncé la manipulation mais
personne n'avait voulu l'entendre les
corps avaient été volés dans des morgues
et dans des cimetières avril 1990 à
paris six mois après le scandale
médiatique
reporters sans frontières organise un
colloque la profession fait son mea
culpa
tout le monde s'est trompé plus ou moins
chacun à sa manière
l'occasion aussi d'analyser les ressorts
de ce raté en roumanie au début de la
révolte
l'information ne circule et pas ou peu
les agences des pays de l'est libérer du
communisme était la seule source l'ouest
n'avait pas d'autre possibilité sérieuse
que de les reprendre
quant à la création du faux charnier
malgré plusieurs enquêtes
les auteurs de la falsification n'ont
pas été identifiés
[Musique]